effervescence à l'association ont rempli
le frigo
ce jeudi marque le début de la
distribution des produits récoltés par
l'association dans le 3e arrondissement
de la capitale
une cagnotte a permis de recueillir plus
de 60000 euros
grâce à cette initiative de 1500 paniers
alimentaires pourront être distribués à
paris lyon toulouse et marseille
pat fruits et légumes variés ou encore
gel douche composeront notamment ses
paniers les étudiants beaucoup souffert
et on a beaucoup plus de travail donc
plus rentrée d'argent
on a vu sur d'autres distributions
alimentaires qui avait énormément de
monde que la demande était constante et
que ça fait les schistes et pas
malheureusement donc on a décidé de
venir en aide un peu ainsi du temps là
et à ses autres associations pour les
bénévoles ont réparti les chercher sur
les réseaux sociaux
ça a été très simple à partir du moment
où on a commencé à poster des des postes
on disait que les distributions
alimentaires allez allez être présente
le 6 mai tout le monde a répondu présent
directement dans la poche a besoin de
les harceler pour venir ça a été quelque
chose de naturel et ça fait vraiment
plaisir à voir dans cette situation
actuelle solidarité et échanges sont les
mots d'ordre au sein de l'association
l'action séduit et permis aux étudiants
de se changer les idées
quand ils vont venir quand ils vont
récupérer leur sac on va essayer d'avoir
le sourire une musique on va vraiment
essayer d'avoir une discussion avec eux
justement pour les faire sentir bien et
que pendant ce moment où ils viennent
dans un moment qui est quand même assez
difficile parce que quand même de venir
chercher des denrées
il cherchait un doute de l'aide se
passent très facile ce genre de choses
ça permet déjà de sortir de chez soi par
rapport au confinement et ces gens ça
fait vraiment plaisir
et en plus de ça va tomber sur des
étudiants super sympa qui font toutes
ces actions est de manière générale sur
la période basse est vraiment toutes ces
actions cumulées pour aider les
étudiants qui permettent un peu de
bah de relativiser sur la période en
soit on est comment on en arrive à être
en bonne santé on arrive à avoir en plus
de ça pas mal de coups de pouce pour
nous aider donc vraiment c'est que du
positif pour cette première étape à
paris la file d'attenté ne désemplit pas
seule condition pour accéder à ces
distributions la présentation de la
carte d'étudiant en une journée
350 étudiants ont pu bénéficier de ces
paniers repas